Çeviri: Cansu BAYRAM
Gözden geçirme: Sancak Gülgen
Rahmetlinin bir sözü üzerine
bir genel çerçevesi olacakmış
noktaları birleştirmek.
O konuşmasını da izlemiştim. Dehşete kapıldım.
Yani, ben nefret ederim geçmişimden.
Geçmişimdeki bütün noktalar,
keşke olmasaydı dediğim şeyler.
Ama daha önemlisi
ben bir hikaye anlatıcısıyım.
Benim için Steve Jobs'ın noktalar dediği
kesin, yerinde duran, analiz edilebilir
--kendi şahsi tarihi içinde olduğu için --
şeyler, bizim için
biz hikaye anlatıcıları için
kuantum parçacıkları gibi.
Bilir misiniz kuantum teorisini?
Kuantum parçacıkları ile uğraşanlar bilirler.
Kuantum parçacığının yerini tespit etmek
mümkün değildir.
Olasılıkları tespit etmek mümkündür.
Biz hikaye anlatıcıları
ben mecburen bunu çizdirdim.
Bizim noktalar, sürekli olarak
gelecekle ilgili.
Hikaye anlatıcıları gelecekten geliyorlar.
Ben de gelecekten geldim buraya.
Şöyle; gideceğim oraya
onların kırmızı bir yazısı vardır
onun önüne çıkacağım,
hikaye anlatılıcığı ile ilgili başlayacağım.
İşte, yüz elli iki yüz kişi olacak.
Hikaye anlatıcıları sürekli yanılır
gelecek konusunda.
Ama, bizim işimiz
gerçekten hikaye anlatırken
bugüne, düne
-- bugün bile bizim için aslında sonrası olan bir an --
Yani bu an bile bizim için sonrası olan bir an.
Çok gelecekten bakıp
belki geçmiş noktaları toplayıp
onlardan geleceğe ilişkin,
dinleyicinin geleceğine ilişkin
bir hikaye yaratmak.
O seyirci, o izleyici için
yeni bir nokta,
yeni bir ihtimal üretmek bizim işimiz.
Sürekli olarak biz de normal insanlar gibi
kendi noktalarımızla, geçmişimizle uğraşıyoruz.
Ama meslek bu meslek olunca
aklımız yalnızca aslında geleceğe çalışıyor.
Ben de o yüzden
bütün hikaye anlatıcıları gibi
ben de gelecekten geliyorum.
Toplumsal olaylara bakıyoruz
geçmişle ilgili,
insanların arzularına bakıyoruz
yine geçmişte kalmış arzular.
Ve bunlardan bir hikaye üretiyoruz.
Bugünün seyircisini anlatıyoruz
ama daha anlatırken değişiyorlar.
Daha ben anlatmayı planladım,
geleceğin ne olacağını gördüm
fakat kalabalığı görmedim.
Şimdi bu kalabalığa göre de
değiştiriyorum konuşmamı.
Yani buradan oraya kadar bakmam gerekiyor.
O zaman ben birazcık daha esnek
bir vücut hareketi ile anlatmalıyım diyorum.
Yani hikaye, noktalar yaratarak
o muğlak noktalardan birine tutunarak
sonra öbürüne sıçrayarak anlatılıyor.
Seyirci de böyle takip ediyor.
Gerçekten ilham vermek üzere anlatılıyor
hikayelerin hepsi.
Şimdi, buraya gelmeden önce
seyirciye nereden bakıyoruz diye düşündüm.
Bir kere hikayeyi anlatınca değişecek
bu seyirci diye bakıyoruz.
Yani yine seyircinin geleceği ile ilgileniyoruz.
Bizim geçmiş için yapabileceğimiz hiçbir şey yok.
Geçmiş için yaptığımız bütün analizler, aslında
gelecek için bir ilham vermek üzere olabilir ancak.
Hatta bazen ilham vermiyoruz
bazen sadece rahatlatıyoruz.
Yani yerin iyi.
Aşk var.
Savaşlar bitebilir.
Barış mümkün.
Aç kalmayacaksın.
Böyle hikayeler de var.
Onlara gidiyoruz, hafif içimizin yağları eriyor.
Gerçek farklı olsa da
bir dayanma enerjisi ile çıkıyoruz.
Hikaye bir işe yarıyor.
Ve ya tam tersine
arzu ettiğimiz ama asla ulaşamayacağımız
noktalara ulaşabileceğimizin hikayesini anlatıyoruz
"Connecting the dots" denen şey;
geçmişteki noktaları birleştirerek
kim olduğunu anlama hikayesi
ancak başarılıysanız ilginç.
Yalnızca başarı öykülerinin böyle geriye dönüp
noktalarını birleştirmenin
bizler için bir manası var.
Halbuki hikaye anlatıcılarının esas dinleyicileri
başarısızlardır.
Sizler.
(Gülüşmeler)
Çünkü buradan sonrası ile ilgileniyoruz.
Hikaye anlatıcısı şöyle anlatır hikayesini:
Küçük bir yerde çalışıyordu, çok yoksuldu
yemek yiyemiyordu.
Sonra, işte
küçük bir yiyecek birşey icat etti kuru ekmeklerden.
Onu sattı para kazandı.
Oradan kendisine küçük bir dükkan aldı,
büyüdü, bilmem ne devleşti,
holding oldu, sonra Ferrari'sini sattı.
Yani bizim hikayelerimizin gerçek dinleyicileri;
başarılı olmak isteyen ve bunun yolunu arayan
hepimiz için geçerli bu.
Aramızda bugün çok başarılı olan birisi bile
belki Ferrari'sini satma hikayesini dinlemek istiyor.
O da başka bir başarı çünkü.
Başarısız olduğu bir noktada ancak
anlatılan hikaye onun için ilginç oluyor.
Bizim anlattığımız hikayeler
çok çeşitli ihtimalleri anlatıyor.
Hani çoklu evren teorileri vardır
son dönemlerde de televizyonlarda,
Amerikan dizilerinde, şurada burada
çok ele alınan bir konu.
Kim bilir neler olacak sorusu yerine
tabii ki birçok şey aynı anda olacak
birçok evrende olacak diye.
Ben böyle bir hikaye yazmıştım.
Genellikle de kendimi hep bu durumda hissederim.
Adamın biri anlatıyor
"Abi" diyor "Garip bir şeyler oluyor bana
mesela geçen gün taksiye bineceğim" diyor.
"Elimi kaldırdım taksi diye
bir baktım arkada bir ben daha var
taksi durmuş biniyor ona" diyor.
"Önümdeki adam,
taksinin önünde de ben varım
elini kaldırmış taksi durmayınca
küfrediyor ona doğru" diyor.
Sonra diyor,
bazen çok garip hissediyorum kendimi
mesela yürüyorum bir yokuştan iniyorum
düştüm, taşlar çarptı.
Bir baktım yanımdaki düşmedi, 'ben' düşmedi
aşağı doğru hızla gidiyor koşarak
toprakları ezerek.
Bir başka ben daha düştüm ve bayılmışım.
Bir başka ben ayağı kalktı, üstünü sirkeledi.
Ben bunların hepsini birden seyrediyorum.
Biz hikayeye başlarken böyle bakıyoruz meseleye bir parça.
Yani ne olacak, ne olursa ne olur,
ne olursa seyirci beğenir,
arzu ettiği şeyi bulur, ilham alır.
Tamamen şurada gördüğünüz bir halde kafa
birçok nokta var, yerleri bile belli değil
ve her noktadan başka noktalara da
başka hareketler var.
Şöyle bir bu işin yaptığımız mesleğin
geçmişine bir bakalım
ve bir mamut avı tahayyül edelim.
Mamut biliyorsunuz filimtrak uzun şeyli
çok lezzetli herhalde
çünkü sürekli avlıyorlar.
Bir kişi var görüyorsunuz orada birtakım
çıplak çıplak daha giyinmeyi bilmeyen
bir araya gelemeyen gerçi ok mok yapmışlar ama
kim oldukları belirsiz bir kalabalık var
ama bir kişi daha var.
Karınları aç
daha öyle toplum kabile mabile değiller,
tek tek ceylan vuruyorlar falan
mamuta gelince öyle tek başına olmuyor.
Sesleniyorlar, gelin diyorlar
haydi avlayalım falan diyorlar.
Yalnız bir kişi daha var dediğim gibi;
bu fotoğrafı çeken.
O biraz tembel.
Veya fazla zayıf.
Çok yiyemiyor.
Mamut eti falan zaten zor.
Fazla zayıf, karakteri bozuk.
Pek kimse sevmiyor onu belki.
Aşağılıyorlar.
Belki köyün palyaçoluğunu yapıyor.
Ama o burada durma
yetkisine sahip tek kişi.
Bakıyor ve geleceği kuruyor aslında.
Diyor ki:
Huu'nun attığı ok
mamutu tam gözünden vurdu.
Huu ile arası düzelsin istiyor.
Oradaki Jee diyor, çok yardıma muhtaçtı,
yanındaki onu kaldırdı
birlikte koştular
ama ikisi de mamutun
ayakları altında ezildiler.
Ama onlar sayesinde mamut devrildi diyor.
Kahramanlar yaratıyor
mümkünse ölmüş kahramanlar yaratıyor.
Değilse, artık elde ne varsa.
Bunları planlıyor.
Buna, şu adama ilişkin hikaye ile
şunu anlatırsam,
mamutla ilgili şunu söylersem
diye birşeyler kuruyor.
Diyor ben bu hikayeyi mutlaka
şimdi bunlar bu mamutu alırlar götürürler
keserler, ateş pişirirler, yerler,
hiç vakitleri kalmaz beni unuturlar.
Onun için ne yapayım diyor
bizim orada şimşek çakmış bir ağaç var, yanmış.
Onun önüne çıkıyor en görünen yer.
Onu kimsenin görmemesine imkan yok.
Ve başlıyor avın hikayesini anlatmaya.
O hikaye anlatıldığı andan itibaren
artık burada gördüğünüz güruh; bir toplumdur.
Kahramanları olan, geçmişleri olan,
noktaları olan.
O noktaların çoğu yalan da olsa.
Masal onları birleştiriyor,
onları bir haline getiriyor,
bir toplum haline getiriyor.
Çünkü birbirlerine muhtaçlar onlar
tek başlarına olsalar yaşayamayacaklar,
var olamayacaklar.
Yeryüzünün en eski mesleği
o bldiğiniz meslek değil, bizim mesleğimiz.
Çünkü biz olmadan biz yokuz.
Biz kavramı yok.
Biz dediğimiz şey ancak hikaye ile olabiliyor.
Hikayesi olmayan hiçbir şey varsayılamaz.
Bugün ticari markalar bile
hikayesi var mı markanın diye soruyorlar.
Çünkü hikayesi yoksa marka da yok.
Bu aslında çok arkaik bir gerçek.
Hikayeler öyle bildiğimiz gibi
yalnızca eğlendiğimiz şeyler değil.
Geçmiş zamanlarda üç şey sayesinde
insanlar birbirleri hakkında bilgi sahibi oluyorlardı.
Tüccarlar, göçebeler ve hikaye anlatıcıları.
Bunlar seyahat ediyordu yeryüzünde çünkü.
Yani o zamanın interneti
bu üç unsurdan oluşuyordu.
Biz bugün internet sayesinde
keşfediyoruz ki;
bütün dünya bir hikayeler dünyası
olarak algılanabilir.
En tehlikelisi ama en tehlikelisi;
tek hikaye olması.
Tek hikaye çok tehlikeli bir şeydir.
Hikayecinin anlattığı hikaye de hikaye olabilir.
Yani bir hikayeci hiçbir zaman size gerçeği anlatmaz.
Hakikati anlatır ama gerçeği anlatmaz,
kendisi hakkında bile gerçeği
anlatmayı tercih etmez.
Elsa Hanım da bize böyle anlatıyor:
Babam beni erkek kılığına soktu,
kervanlara götürdü.
Kervanda da bir tane Kör Fehim diye bir meddah varmış.
Kör Fehim,
ona hikaye anlatıcılığını
öğretme kararını almış
kızın ısrarları sonucunda.
Demiş ki:
Bak, bizim hikayelerimiz
her zaman başka türlü anlatılır.
Her anlatıda mutlaka hikayeyi değiştiririz.
Eğer kar yağıyorsa bizim kurt hikayesi farklılaşır.
Eğer zenginlerin karşısında anlatıyorsak
onlara farklı bir üslupla anlatırız en azından hikayeyi.
Eğer bir hacı kafilesi gelmişse
aynı hikayeyi onlara başka türlü bir ilham
ve arzu uyandıracak şekilde anlatırız.
Aynı hikaye gece, gündüz.
şu memlekette, şu ortamda,
savaşta, biz esirken başka türlü anlatılır.
Asla ve asla hikaye elle tutulamaz
hikayecinin yeteneği de hikaye bulmakta değil;
hikaye anlatmaktadır.
Tıpkı şey gibi düşünebilirsiniz;
bir fıkrayı bir arkadaşınız anlatıyor
çok gülüyorsunuz,
öbürü anlatıyor hiç gülmüyorsunuz.
İşte bunun ikisi arasındaki fark
bizim mesleğimiz.
Kör Fehim bir şey daha söylüyor. Diyor ki:
Bir kural var biz hikaye anlatıcıları arasında.
Tabii ki o zamanın
hikaye anlatıcıları arasında.
Çilli Murat'ın anlattığı hiçbir hikayeyi
ben anlatmam.
Benim 800 tane hikayem var,
onda da 600 tane falan vardır.
Bir hikaye anlatıcısın anlattığı hikayeyi
bir başka hikaye anlatıcısı anlatmaz,
yoksa loncadan atılır.
Bu aslında gördüğünüz gibi tek hikaye,
yalnızca tek bir hikaye anlatmayı engelleyecek
bir mesleki karar.
Şu anda yeni bir dünyaya adım atıyoruz.
Bu söz kim bilir kaç kere söylenmiştir
ama bana gerçekten öyle gibi geliyor.
Hikaye anlatıcılığının altın çağına
biz adım atıyoruz.
İnternet sayesinde bize bizi anlatan
hikayelerin sayısı artıyor.
Bizi anlatan hikayelerin sayısı arttıkça
biz dediğimiz şeyin
çeşitlemeleri artırıyor.
Gidemediğimiz
o gitmesek de görmesek de o köy bizim köyümüzdür
inanışı var ya. Bu ahlak dışı
bir inanış zaten.
Hiç değilse hikayeler
bu anlayışı değiştiriyor
orayı gönlümüzde bizim
haline getirebiliyor.
Bakınca görmeyiz biz.
Gösterilince görüyoruz.
Bize gösterecek insanlar lazım.
Hikaye anlatıcıları böyle varlıklar.
Hikayelerin artması aynı
ilk hikayecinin yaptığı gibi,
ortak bir hikaye toplarlanıyor
ve hepimizi bir araya getiriyor.
Anlatıcıya, uyandırmayı nasip eden
ilham perilerine teşekkürlerle...
(Alkış)